رفح ومراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت وهشام وتيره
القصف تصاعدت خلال هذين اليومين على رفح
ما الذي اسفرت عنه وما هو الوضع
الان بالفعل مياده القصف الاسرائيلي على
رفح بات يتخذ مسار مختلف عن ربما الاسابيع
والاشهر الماضيه القصف الاسرائيلي بات
مركز على مدينه رفح خلال اليومين الماضيين
بتنا نشهد مزيد من الغارات الاسرائيليه
وكما تحدث الزميل اسماعيل ايضا القصف
الاسرائيلي على المناطق
المحيطه او المناطق الفاصله ما بين
خانيونس ورفح شهدت ايضا غارات اسرائيليه
عنيفه كذلك المنطقه الحدوديه على مدار
اليومين الماضيين بات القصف الاسرائيلي
قريب من الحدود المصريه مع مدينه رفح
القصف ايضا كان خلال فجر هذا اليوم على
روضه للاطفال تابعه لهذه الروضه كان تحولت
الى مركز للنازحين الفلسطينيين كان هناك
عشرات من العائلات الفلسطينيه تتواجد في
هذه الروضه التابعه التي التي اتخذها
الناس مركزا للايواء وقصفها الجيش
الاسرائيلي وقصف محيطها وبالتالي كان هناك
شهيدين شهدت من جراء عمليه القصف
الاسرائيلي على هذه الروضه بالتالي القصف
الاسرائيلي على رفح بات اكثر عنفا وبات
القصف المدفعي كذلك في المناطق الشرقيه
مستمر ومتواصل وبالتالي هذه ربما تتزامن
مع التهديدات الاسرائيليه التي تستهدف
مدينه رفح وبدء العمليه في مدينه رفح كما
يتحدث وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي بالتالي
القصف الاسرائيلي على رفح ربما يتخذ شكل
مختلف وله خصوصيه خاصه عندما نتحدث عن
مدينه رفح التي باتت ما ماوى لالاف من
النازحين الفلسطينيين هي المركز الاساسي
الان للنزوح وبالتالي هناك مليون و300 ال
نسمه يتواجدون في رفح في ظل ظروف كارثيه
واي قصف اسرائيلي على مدينه رفح هو يوقع
عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى عمليه توديع
الشهداء كانت قبل قليل وخلال اليومين
الماضيين ايضا شهدت عمليه توديع للشهداء
كان هناك قصف لمنازل مدنيه فلسطينيه وكان
هناك اكثر من 20 شهيد من عائله الهمص
وعائله حجازي وبالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي
على مدينه رفح يوقع عشرات من الشهداء
والجرحى بسبب عمليه الاكتظاظ للنازحين
الفلسطينيين في كل هذه المنازل المدنيه
الفلسطينيه ا القصف ايضا مستمر على مناطق
وسط القطاع المناطق مخيم المغازي مخيم
البريج وكذلك مخيم النصيرات المناطق
الحدوديه الشماليه والشرقيه و
مدينه دير البلح ايضا تعرضت الى قصف عنيف
من المدفعيه ومن الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه قصفت منزلا في منطقه حكر
الجامع وهي في المناطق الشرقيه لدير البلح
وكان هناك عدد من الشهداء والجرحى وما
زالت عملي البحث جاريه عن مزيد من هؤلاء
الشهداء تحت انقاض هذا هذا المنزل الذي
استهدفته الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
فجر هذا اليوم ودير البلح عندما نتحدث
عنها ايضا هي مركز للنزوح ومركز لعمليات
الاواء خاصه من مدينه غزه الذين يجبرهم
الجيش الاسرائيلي على النزوح بعد اعتقال
الرجال وترك النساء للنزوح الى تلك
المناطق في وسط القطاع من رفح مراسل
الجزيره هشام زقوط شكرا جزيلا لك